hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar glassware washers and result
reliability wash worry away
i am marie stone of labrutz and i'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by lab conco to learn more visit
labconco.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
jordan henderson product manager
labconco corporation
jordan you may now begin your
presentation
hello everyone thank you for taking time
out of your day
to listen to my presentation on
glassware washers and results
reliability washing your worry away my
name is jordan henderson i'm the product
manager for the glassware washer line
here at the laptop
corporation in kansas city missouri
uh on the agenda today
we're going to discuss potential sources
and the impact
of contamination and results carry over
on results
we're also going to identify and discuss
common highly sensitive analytical
techniques that are found throughout a
variety of laboratory environments
we're also going to identify and discuss
common laboratory contaminants things to
look out for and then finally we're
going to discuss how implementing a
laboratory glassware washer can help
provide consistent reliable results and
sort of serve as a buyer's guide for
when you're evaluating and assessing
whether or not a glassware washer will
work for you
so really the first question that we
need to ask is what is carryover so
really this is a term
used to describe a certain type of
contamination
oftentimes
this can be broken down into two two
segments we have a sample to sample
result carryover and then we have
reagent to sample carryover now the
first type of uh
carryover the sample the sample
is really when a previous sample
is present in subsequent runs of a
workflow or an experiment oftentimes
this manifests itself in ghost peaks
during blank runs and is really
responsible for generating a lot of
false positives and subsequent runs of
the you know experiments or workflows
the second type of that reagent to
sample uh carry over
is basically
subscribes to
uh
continuous front instruments so high
throughput high volume instrumentation
where potentially aspiration errors can
happen and then
miss sampled reagents are present in
subsequent runs as well
so why should be why should you be
concerned with result carryover well
contamination obviously is a very
important issue and it's a serious issue
that should always be considered
obviously carryover will
result in errors in analysis
and quite frankly as a laboratory
professional working in a laboratory
results are really the product that
you're responsible for
um
when you don't have quality of results
or consistent results this is obviously
going to a calling to question the
reliability and quality of your
laboratory
and more importantly this is going to
cost time and money so it's going to
cost money having to redo
experiments or workflows
you know wasting money on reagent
and then also it's going to waste
laboratories professional
a laboratory professional's time
by having to redo
experimentation troubleshooting the
analyzer making sure that qc
calibrations are done things like that
when trying to limit sources of
contamination it's important to be aware
of where these sources of contamination
can actually come from
in a general lab environment there are a
variety of environmental factors that we
should just be aware of humidity
temperature the presence of light can
all have a negative impact on sample
quality in the laboratory there are
a number of molecules or tests um that
are very sensitive to these factors um
specifically
biliary testing is very sensitive to
light as well as vitamin testing
so it's always essential to maintain
environmental conditions
from sample collection to analysis to
really ensure
you're producing a quality result
the presence of substandard reagents in
your experimentation is something to
always be aware of as well
um when using older expired reagents
those can have a negative impact on the
quality of results that you're producing
obviously for reagents that have a
manual component and they have to be
prepped
proper preparation of those reagents is
very very important because that can
also impact your results
and then of course when it comes to
purchasing or acquiring these reagents
for your experimentations
it's always important to make sure you
get them from a reputable dealer that is
focused on quality because if you are
getting cheaper less quality reagents
that problem is going to manifest in
your results because you're
inheriting a quality issue from that
manufacturer
another source of contamination is the
laboratory professional itself
um
when it comes to personnel contamination
that really depends or is
really dependent on the use
of personal protective equipment um in
in the case of face masks and gloves i'm
really limiting um
the contaminants being exposed that way
um additionally
when you're dealing with laboratory
professionals not every laboratory
professional is going to
do the same workflow exactly the same
way every time and that definitely is
the case from person to person to person
so there's just more
opportunity to go ahead and introduce
potential contaminants that can
negatively affect your results on the
when it comes to that
instrument contamination as well is
something to be considered again i
previously mentioned
that in cases of
instrumentation that's really automating
a process
when those processes miss sample or
there is a problem something breaks
there's a potential to
expose certain
modules or steps in a workflow to
unexpected reagents or samples that can
potentially negatively affect your
results
later down the line
finally worth mentioning
visitor entry obviously locking down an
area um limiting the exposure
of people coming in and out of your
laboratory can um
further reduce the
the introduction of contaminants into
your lab and therefore
provide a better result
at the end
and finally dirty glassware is something
to always be considered when trying to
limit the exposure of contaminants into
your experiments
oftentimes
residual chemical contamination remains
on glassware which will negatively
impact
the results that you're trying to
produce
additionally residual sample
contamination is something that can be
be considered
when it comes to
really
making sure that you're producing the
best quality results as well
well moving on so we've talked about
contamination
what is it where does it come from
what are things to be looking out for
when it comes to reagent and sample
contamination now let's talk about some
procedures that are commonly found
throughout laboratories you know that
are super sensitive uh to
potential exposure to these types of
things
so here's a list we're going to talk
about hplc uh ultra high performance
liquid liquid chromatography
supercritical fluid chromatography
um
liquid chromatography in conjunction
with max spectrometry and then
polymerase chain reaction just briefly
so what is high performance liquid
chromatography or hplc so obviously it's
just a technique used to separate
identify and quantify components in a
mixture
this technique is a pretty ubiquitous
technique found throughout laboratories
but it's especially found in analytical
laboratories
in general the hplc procedure involves
pumps moving solvents
containing
a mixture of compounds through columns
which is known as the stationary phase
that is generally comprised of absorbent
materials
when those components actually hit that
stationary phase or the absorbent
material they will interact differently
causing them to separate into their
individual components
then we can later identify those
this is
commonly found
in research settings medical settings
and manufacturing settings
moving on to ultra high performance
liquid chromatography or uh plc
it's really a very similar method to
liquid chromatography
uh and it's still trying to separate
different compounds found in a mixture
um
however it's really kind of just usually
utilizing a higher pressure to
pull apart those compounds in that
mixture again this is going to be
commonly found in a pharmaceutical
medical and research setting
moving on to supercritical fluid
chromatography or
or s
fc
um
again we're still
using principles similar to high
performance liquid chromatography uh
it's just the main difference here is
that
supercritical fluid chromatography uses
a supercritical fluid such as carbon
dioxide as the mobile phase
this is used in the analysis and
purification of specifically of low to
moderate weight
low to moderate molecular weight
compounds
those that are
thermally liable and chiral compounds as
well
this is a less
used technique but it's definitely used
in
a lot in the pharmaceutical sector
um moving on and i i know we've just
touched on it on a few uh chromo
chromatography techniques but uh
definitely wanted to sit here and hit on
um the liquid chromatography and mass
spectrometry uh method so obviously with
the liquid chromatography we're
separating out compounds
in a mixture
again using the mobile phase and
stationary phase interaction to pull
those
those mixtures of or those compounds out
of the mixture so we can identify them
but in
liquid chromatography mass spectrometry
we're actually
then pairing that with mass analysis as
well
this is used to analyze a variety of
compounds
biochemical organic or inorganic
compounds and this can commonly be found
and is used in biotechnology
the environmental
sector food and agriculture and
cosmetics as well
uh another um
sensitive analytical technique that is
found in a variety of laboratories is
going to be your polymerized change re
chain reaction um
techniques
this technique
is really designed to amplify and target
a specific sequence of dna and rna
there are
the two main ones are going to be
real-time pcr and then quantitative
methods which is also known as endpoint
pcr detection
this is used to analyze following the
following compounds it could be
pathogens so it could be a bacterial
pathogen such as
e coli or salmonella species
it could be a virus it could be a
hepatitis virus or a norovirus and a
common this is this technique is going
to be commonly found in biotechnology
the medical field
specific specifically the clinical lab
the food industry and also found in
research settings
now that we have identified some
uh pretty sensitive analytical
techniques i think it's
definitely worth our time to just
identify and be aware of common
contaminants that are found throughout
the laboratory
some of the residual contaminants that
we often see are solvents um these
solvents can be uh
really anything mostly organic inorganic
or polar
we also see a lot of residual
contaminants being acids and bases
there are a lot of
recommended glassware washing procedures
where the glassware actually goes
through a
acid pre-rinse to really kind of loosen
up stubborn contaminants so it's always
important to properly wash glassware
because if that's the case
that this doesn't happen
we can introduce
residual acids and vases
into your experiments later on down the
road
waxes as well this is
specific to extraction processes waxes
are generally
hard
sticky substances that are difficult to
clean
and so a proper thorough cleaning of
really any really reusable glassware is
important and then of course detergent
itself
can be a contaminant
oftentimes
people equate more detergent with more
clean and we'll discuss this in a moment
that's not always the case
another contaminant is going to be your
fatty or proteinus matter this tends to
be contaminants consisting of plant or
animal based samples
oftentimes we do see this with kelball
acid digestion
also in crude fat and fiber analysis
really it's when that undigested and
residual acid digestion products
remain on this glassware
this is where we can get that adverse
effect on result quality overall
kind of
leaning into the acid digestion as well
is when we start to look at burnt or
charred residues
bird charge residues
can oftentimes consist of solution and
mixture
uh that have been left on a boy
on a heating plate or a heat source
that
get burnt or charred onto reusable
glassware and that can obviously cause
quality issues if that glassware isn't
properly cleaned
again these tend to be very sticky and
hard to clean substances
and removing the residue requires a
a repeatable cleaning workflow
so the next type of contaminant is going
to be microbes or bacteria
this contaminant
really kind of affects the useful life
of the reagents and buffer due to it's
buildup over time it has an impact on
the stability of the suspensions and
solutions
um it also affects
um negatively
either in the inhibition or the
catalysis of
various reactions
um this again again leads to the
uh formation of unwa
unwanted reaction products and
additional impurities
the limiting the presence of these is
very important
if you ever are in doubt
it's always a safe bet to autoclave
finally the last type of contaminant
could potentially be the detergent that
you're using or the any other cleaning
agents
residual detergents or other cleaning
chemicals
left over can produce undesirable
undesirable results this is really due
to the
fact that detergents have a very wide
range of ph they can range anywhere from
2 to 13 on the ph scale
they also consist of varying chemical
compounds that serve different functions
and also detergents can be enzymatic so
they can have a pretty negative effect
on any chemical reaction that you're
really trying to control
uh and produce a specific product
when in doubt less is more um
adding more detergent doesn't mean
you're going to get more clean glassware
so speaking of detergent i think it's
important to kind of understand the role
of detergent when it comes to producing
clean glassware as well
um really the main parts of glassware
are surfactants carriers and chelators
and builders
for the most part surfactants or surface
active agents
are just molecules that consist of the
hydrophilic heads and hydrophobic tails
and really they're responsible for
reducing the
surface tension of the solution that
they're in uh this helps kind of sweep
away potential contaminants that are
being uh being lifted off of a glassware
that you're trying to wash
another part of a detergent is something
known as a carrier and this really just
aids in dissolving soil on
glassware of moving on uh chelators
or another component that are often
found in detergents
um really what a chelator does is that
it binds to three metal ions and then it
sequesters them and
allows them uh to be removed from the
from a surface in a solution like down a
drain
and then of course we have our builders
and really a builder is
a part of a detergent
simply to emulsify buffer and soften
contaminants in the water
so when trying to identify what type of
detergent that you should use we do have
this chart here on the screen from a
general sense
what detergent is going to work best for
whatever contaminant you're trying to
remove
when it comes to heavy scales
strong
mineral acids of
a 0 to a 2 on a ph scale
is going to be going to be preferred
when dealing with salts oxides and
metallics
mild acids are preferred
when trying to remove light oil and
other neutral particulates
really detergents that fall between a
5.5 and an 8.5 on the ph scale
are going to be preferred
mild alkaline detergents anything from
an 8.5 to 11 are going to be used to
remove oils and films
um
most commonly uh especially in the
laboratory setting
detergents
are alkaline in nature falling between
this 11 to 12.5
ph scale and these are going to be used
to remove natural oils fats and resins
and then anything stronger than a 12.5
is going to be considered corrosive and
these are going to be used for heavy
greases and soils
uh
obviously when you're picking out uh
your detergent you're trying to remove
something but it's also important to
take into account uh the substrate that
you're trying to remove that contaminant
from
when dealing with aluminum soft metals a
mild alkaline alkaline to modestly
acidic
detergents are preferred
when it comes to mild steel
um
it's just important to control corrosion
so we have to make sure that things are
properly rinsed and dried appropriately
when considering plastics
plastics are are plastic they're
resistant to a broad range of aqueous
cleaners
now when it comes to stainless steel for
the most part alkaline detergents are
the preferred method
for cleaning stainless
and then when it comes to glass
borosilicate glass
this type of substrate is resistant to
a wide range of detergents and so it
it really lends itself to a variety of
options
so
moving on why do we ever why do we even
need to implement a glassware washer so
there are a lot of benefits to
implementing a glassware washer and here
in the next few slides we'll go over
kind of features to look for
obviously the reason why to implement a
glassware washer is because a glassware
washer is a product that
is designed with laboratories in mind
the components that comprise this
laboratory glassware washer
um
will provide greater performance
increased reliability when it comes to
glassware cleanliness
it has the ability to standardize and
automate
the glassware washing task
glassware washers also are resistant to
harsh
laboratory chemicals that are fine found
throughout the laboratory environment
and it will also limit the exposure to
potential workplace injuries like bro
like broken glass
so really what should we look for uh
when we're considering implementing a
glassware washer so
really we're going to look at the
components of construction
oftentimes glassware washers are going
to come
built out of 304 stainless steel or
higher
when it comes to longevity reliability
of the unit
always look for
for reliance on less plastic components
moving on when it comes to
the actual you know
nuts and bolts of the glassware washer
unit that you're considering
really the
the power of the pumps that are
incorporated into this
the water circulation rate generally
needs to be at 96
gallons per minute or higher
excuse me and the separation and if they
can if they can separate the circulation
pump from the drain pump uh that's a
plus because that limits the potential
for cross-contamination of dirty drain
water being recirculated
by the circulation pump
when it comes to the heating level that
you're trying to get to
the maximum water temperature
is important because that allows water
to further penetrate stubborn
contaminants on glassware or whatever
you're trying to wash
i would look for a minimum level of 100
i'm sorry minimum
temperature of 165 degrees fahrenheit
which is 74 degrees c
that's still low
oftentimes there are glassware washers
that can reach 93 degrees c or 199
degrees fahrenheit pretty easily so
that's what i would shoot for
some other special specialized features
depending on what you're trying to wash
from a glassware standpoint um whether
you have wide mouth or narrow neck
glassware direct injection spindles uh
are going to be very important what this
allows for is to
um to properly clean erlenmeyer flask
and other narrow neck glassware by
injecting a wash rinse uh water into
that piece of glassware to thoroughly
clean the inside of that so you're not
so you're
removing residual
reagent or sample
also this allows when it comes to drying
to
go ahead and provide forced air drying
into that glassware to make sure the
inside is properly dried as well
when it comes to that drying phase or
that drying step of
of that wash program
really need to
be in the 70 to 80 degrees c range to
quickly dry glassware
very important you don't want to wait
all day just
to have dry glassware
also worth mentioning
the ability to incorporate pure water
rinses
again there are some washing procedures
that um
recommend it there are other ones that
require it having a glassware washer
that can accommodate uh
a pure water rinse from pure from a
water purification
unit is important because that further
removes impurities that might remain on
glassware
additionally
on the user interface
of the glassware washer is very very
important
being able to interact with something um
making sure it's user friendly easy to
navigate is important because
we
because
user frustration
should always be be limited right
in the case of having standardized
procedures or wash procedures it's
important to have the ability to data
log and export that data just to have a
running tally or a track record and
making sure that you're hitting the
measures that you need to hit
and then additionally clear and specific
alarms um not having
um to go reference a manual somewhere
else to see what's going on with your
glassware washer is very very uh
important because it takes time saves
energy and it saves frustration
other specialized features include
the potential to incorporate hepa filter
forced air drying
making sure that we're not pulling in
dirty room air
and blowing it on your newly cleaned
glassware and then potentially
incorporating that into workflows and
then affecting your results negatively
the ability to monitor water quality is
also very important
that will
give you a real-time representation of
yes my glassware is getting cleaned and
yes i am confident that we can use this
glassware over and over and over again
and not have it negatively impact
the results uh
additionally uh having soft water having
a water softener
having a water softener is important
because water quality varies from region
to region from municipality to
municipality so if the case of water
hardness
we're introducing
potential contaminants that way so using
a water softener is very important
additionally
having a robust ecosystem of accessories
now using a glassware washer should make
cleaning your glassware as easy as
possible
accessories should be able to
accommodate
standard pieces of glassware and not so
standard pieces of glass were like
pipettes and graduated cylinders
so being able to
adapt and change to
the mountain of glassware that
can be found in laboratories is
important
all right so just to recap
by implementing a glassware washer
you will be able to free up a laboratory
professional's time
by automating the messy unwanted task of
you know cleaning glassware you will not
only be able to do that but you'll be
able to produce uh repeatable reliable
cleanability results for your glassware
you can also standardize resource
consumption so from
a water and energy perspective
and then import also
and most importantly you will limit the
the potential for workplace injuries
with broken glassware uh by allowing the
glassware washer to
take over this task for you
again my name is jordan henderson
product manager for the glassware washer
line here at labconco i thank you for
your time
and i would like to open the floor to
any questions
thank you jordan for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
let's get started our first question is
what are some common contaminants found
in labware
uh that's excuse me that's a really good
question um common contaminants can you
know
range widely obviously i mentioned um
just residual contaminants from workflow
like acids and bases that are either
organic
or inorganic or polar in nature
it could be residual
samples anywhere from biological samples
like
serum and plasma to
wastewater remnants
from
water that is going to be treated so
they can
properly treat that
additionally there could be
proteins or dnas on glassware and
especially
residual
detergent that is left over from
the washing process so
those are just a few contaminants
again it's always important to be aware
of the inputs that you're putting into
your workflows and and what you're using
your glassware for because then you can
kind of quickly identify hey potentially
this could be affecting um the quality
of our results because
it's remaining in the glassware that
we're using
thank you next question
what is a contaminant sensitive method
commonly used in a laboratory setting
um so
a common
contaminant sensitive method is going to
be hplc that's a pretty ubiquitous
workflow um always used to separate and
then identify uh molecules or compound
other compounds
from my specific experience being a
clinical lab scientist i did a lot of
nucleic acid amplification techniques um
in the molecular
department of the clinical lab that i
worked in
so that's one that i am very familiar
with and it's always important to
definitely be aware of those inputs
because when you're doing those
amplification techniques um
if you introduce mistakes you are
essentially amplifying that mistake and
then that definitely ruins your results
and definitely
um
takes time money energy to um
redo all that work so definitely those
are some
pretty common sensitive techniques that
are used in laboratories
thank you
it looks like we have time for one more
question what role does detergent play
in removing labware contaminants
uh so you know not too
over complicated i mean as you guys know
detergent is what we use to
to clean really any substrate that we
can we're really focused on trying to
reuse and and make sure it's not
impacting
um our results um
you know later down the line so
of the role detergent is an important
one obviously we had touched on some of
the components of detergent so
surfactants the carriers the chelators
and the builders and all those things
really work together to help you know
penetrate those stubborn contaminants
gently lift them off the glassware um
while um preserving the integrity of
that substrate
for later use and so yeah it's just a
very important component to consider to
be aware of and
really kind of should facilitate
that workflow that you're that you're
using a case in point in that is if you
are trying to detect something and
that is sodium based and then you're
using a sodium-based detergent
you're probably gonna have to find a new
detergent because that
residual
detergent on the glassware if it remains
is going to impact on what you're trying
to detect so that could falsely elevate
your results so yeah
interesting
thank you jordan do you have any final
comments for our audience
um no i just wanted to again thank
everybody for their time today really do
appreciate you guys um um taking the
time sitting down with me and listening
to my presentation on glassware washers
and results reliability so um
so yeah i just thank you and have a
great rest of your day
all right well thank you again jordan
for your time today and your important
research we would also like to thank lab
roots and our sponsor labconco for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time goodbye